[Music]
okay I got a couple are you the [ __ ]
they're really really short but there's
three of them oh I really like these
ones so next level you have a phone and
a laptop book yeah this one doesn't get
good internet so I'm like my relay on
the phone she's like in a movie she's
considered a hacker she's got multiple
multiple devices yeah they don't have
GPS in those old shows I know I'm like
from like mm that's truly jack power
Bauer's like where's the who are the
coordinates give me Chloe give me the
information if you watch the old movies
and stuff and they're like on the flip
phones and they're like typing like
texting someone in secret it's just an
excel sheet
it's so bad okay and where they [ __ ]
okay my my wife and I have been together
for quite a long time I love her to
death
she is gorgeous she is beautiful yeah
she is super smart and also incredibly
humble so I was playing a video game the
other day and apparently there's a tick
tock trend where if you walk in naked
you record their reaction so my wife did
this and instead of me reacting how she
expected to which is like being over the
top turned on I was scared out of my
mind I was absolutely terrified I did
not know what this figure was coming at
me and because I reacted very poorly
she's talking about me because he told
the story yesterday not living here oh
my extremely gorgeous wife wait this is
for real yeah yeah she tried to tick
tock my ass right oh my god we got
finally here this what the [ __ ] Oh Nicky
jumped me naked what this well I did
that too I know it's really similar to
reading the offer for Julie
yeah yeah she keeps us we got it we got
it no I didn't get it stream like
gorgeous wife got really upset because
she expected me to be turned on she
cried a little bit she is very sensitive
she was very self-aware and that she
shouldn't be crying over it you're like
the reddit post this was the faster
internet connection
definitely an [ __ ] II I sexually
harassed her 24/7 oh my god but this
time this was the one time she was naked
and I didn't am I the [ __ ] yes he's
definitely the [ __ ] I don't think
he's meaning to be the [ __ ] but it is
kind of an [ __ ] he's an [ __ ] but
you scared us we all don't make perfect
moves at all times do we do we do you if
I didn't to Bart he would for sure have
an instant boner like instantly I'm not
as gorgeous the boner is not what we're
having a problem with right now the
issue is how I reacted in it oh it's you
yes oh you're very similar this guy I
reacted like you what the [ __ ] is first
of all there's a camera in your face
right it's like this right and then
second of all I see that first I'm like
what's the what's the [ __ ] is going on
because I all of a sudden have nowhere
guys I got I got headphones on and
listen to this [ __ ] and then I'm gonna
play a game and then I look over because
somebody's here in my dark in my room
it's been cloudy as [ __ ] complete the
dark so I was like yo what the [ __ ] and
then yeah I posted it I mean this oh the
wife I think I found the video okay
there's a video called
tick tock tick tock trend gun
embarrassingly wrong you can see the
sheer horror on my face um like I didn't
even notice she was naked yet I was just
like yo what the [ __ ] is that somebody
comes up behind you and they have a
camera you're like what the who's the
absolute that decided to scare you when
you're peacefully playing a video thank
you so much maybe the wife is the
[ __ ] like you could have got a heart
attack
thank you and that's why it's such a
debate in this ready
laughter after he did that he didn't
give you the reaction you wanted i was
super-embarrassed
and i looks like that's not the reaction
that i think the wife was expecting at
all have you have you watched videos on
it they don't just like it's usually a
little they're kind of far away they
throw the towel so the guy gets like
what's that he has time to process it
doesn't have like noise-canceling
[ __ ] head yeah maybe the chick is the
sole innocent okay I think so the next
one um the next one is Steve so um okay
am I the [ __ ] I woke up this morning
I could do this one if you want the
[ __ ]
I was so excited to see my gorgeous
beautiful 10 out of 10 wife like this
girl is [ __ ] stunning I'm like I
always say all this [ __ ] guy like really
as his wife okay
so I go and find her shoes on the patio
I greet her I say good morning she goes
I'm mad at you
I'm like for why all I want in life is
to please you
and she says I spent two hours building
the perfect Zen garden in Animal
Crossing it was based around the rock
that gives you resources that only
spawns in one particular location one
time and when I woke up this morning all
the rocks on our island were destroyed
and I don't understand why a monster
would do such things and I was like I
didn't know that I could break the rocks
by eating fruit and I destroyed her rock
and her Zen garden and really upset her
and by the [ __ ] I don't even think
these people are real to be honest like
I think the wife's the [ __ ] in this
one yeah yeah absolutely not it's just a
video game
no absolutely not if you know this game
I don't know what's going on anymore so
I had to pick one there are only so many
rocks in the game and they don't come
around all the time and they never come
back in the same place Nelson this this
chicks way overreacting it's just a
video it's just a video I heard
Nikki again yeah it is is the Steve the
[ __ ] but what was the intent right I
don't think either of them were trying
to be the [ __ ] because the guy in
this didn't know that he didn't know his
own strength and breaking rocks [ __ ] up
though he destroyed all the rocks on
their Island the guy also didn't realize
that after the fourth rock was destroyed
maybe that's the one can be destroyed
your guy just kept eating fruit and
breaking rocks yeah you know I want to
hear the other side so what was would
you want out of the gold but to give to
your wife probably because you know what
half my [ __ ] income goes and paid for
bridges and inclines in this goddamn no
I think the in this story at least the
wife made him pay for the rest of the
bridge she already paid for half of it
but she made it do you guys not live
together it's not the same it's an
island but we don't yeah you still make
your own money I have my own house we
were separated yeah and my house has
three bedrooms and an attic his has one
bedroom because he doesn't make as much
money mine has three bedrooms now does
it
well you've been working thank you so
you guys sign the prenup you guys can't
move in together I mean we don't want to
really really good in the stock market
it's sta okay market on the game and I
just made millions so yeah I'm probably
so it would be kind of like if someone
stole all of your turnips like before
you made those millions because you set
it all up in a way as a particular way
but they didn't know that the turnips
mean and did anything this is take a
vote I have apologized formally message
I apologize well yeah thank you
I apologized I made her I brought her
dark chocolates from the store I I made
the bed and I paid for the rest of the
bridge and she says she forgave me but I
still feel like an [ __ ] I don't think
he's an [ __ ] I really don't I don't I
don't the wife and ask for who's that I
don't like anyone so I don't think it
okay what someone has to be a national
in this situation right someone's got to
be there
this is how a dog feels when it poops on
the ground then you rub his nose in it
yep okay he's like I made this for you
yeah I was leaving a trail mix for you
last one okay okay my extremely gorgeous
shot she got hotter and hotter it's a
different couple despite this is
unrealistic beauty standards all alone
back when she was my girlfriend I came
up with a really genius long-form prank
in which I slowly dropped clues that I
might be colorblind I started off with
things that were like maybe like I would
call it a red car Orange
what a shame you believe this [ __ ]
believes me that I thought a red car was
orange anyways
I kept this prank going and I would
drops all hens month after month and in
and it would be so subtle that she would
believe my [ __ ] lies that's so stupid
that's come in there after about a year
she suggested that maybe I should see an
eye specialist the dumb [ __ ] anyway I
thought she would react more
horrifically I thought she would treat
me like I was a child I thought she
would think that I was really stupid but
because she didn't react the way I had
planned after this extremely long prank
I just started telling people she
reacted that way because it's funnier
and it makes them laugh but she won't
play along with my joke
she keeps correcting me during the
stories am I the [ __ ] or is this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that believed my stupid
little lies and wanted me to seek help
the [ __ ] you actually just described
my side of the story that's how I've
been telling the story perfect oh yeah
this happened to you flawless wait does
happen to you too yeah you did good wait
this is you guys again I think that what
I would use that trial to clear my good
name after the second time I was like
wow this is maybe a coincidence yeah
so same sure now it's for sure you two
again yeah I don't know I mean like cuz
I don't know if if my husband would
admit that like that's not really what
but let's just say it is in your case
would you think of it like I mean like
for me like one and a half this similar
thing happened to me and it happened I
was like you're like you said you were a
colleague line and I was just like hey
maybe you should see a specialist and
then every time he tells the story it's
like who she treated me like I was a
[ __ ] eighty she's like oh can you
read can you see this color and I'm like
that's not what happened but everyone
laughs and so he's like no it's funny
though so let me just tell you the funny
the color blind test you're like oh
Jesus like it was funny it was funny
it's funny them remember all that [ __ ]
was I like oh Jesus you just see a
specialist or was I like oh I hope you
were like that one story that's what I
did
[Laughter]
Oh Steve you a big trouble man at least
ah at least she moved on from all I
really I wonder if it that's what's
healthy about it is like the healthy
thing is this background photo if
everyone can see here that she doesn't
actually mean all the things that she's
saying no no and I just have a quick one
okay hey ready as well yeah so hey my uh
you get serviced in here my wife and I
yeah I do and cut my wife and I we do
this method called pulling out the
arrows I guess it's [ __ ] so yeah the
arrows went back out any time back in we
pulled out arrows before any of these I
post really it's not a technique that we
still use
how you guys got to go to the beach
again and do another round of arrow
polling thinking so she's I could see
that there's a bunch of hold up here
this was pretty therapeutic for me yes
this was my arrows being pulled out okay
well they're not arrows anymore they're
that you guys are doing the knife trick
she's being spun on the wheel and some
of the knives hit no honestly I just
tried to pick stories that were told a
million times on JK already and do it in
the airway it worked
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]